Daily Mail reports new save San
Francisco gets $4 million in funding
from billionaires even as more than
40,000 crimes are recorded across the
city this year and office vacancy rates
are at
34% and then you see my favorite is like
now you see these like I love when the
media puts out these propaganda pieces
it's like the most uh the people with
the happiest the happiest places to live
in America and it's all of these cities
and you're like how is that possible
when the crime is this high and you look
at the index about like what actually
they con Ed to mean happiness and it's
and it tends to be things like abortion
rights and and all these other things
like killing babies Mak you exactly if
that makes you happy then that's fine
but it's like nobody learns their
lessons in these cities anymore I just
don't see anything changing of course it
like I said it could be because I'm
younger and I just don't have the
perspective of however many years yeah
look San Francisco can be saved how
really with the billionaires the bil
there there is a there is a billionaire
who could save it which
one musk no which one please Bruce
Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump
could yeah he saved New York City he's
pretty so juliani Giuliani was great
sure sure but Donald Trump is is
credited with turning a New York round
you know you know about this Ron you
know about this right tell me this
particular narrative so as The Story
Goes New York in the 80s was was a crime
ridden hell hole I mean and into the 90s
you had the the subway vigilante that
people were cheering on because they
were so sick and tired of the crime and
uh it's crazy for me to have to to look
at these photos of the old Subways of
how it used to be that the ' 80s that
was that was the that was the 70s it was
and and that was it was Ed cotch who who
began the process of
reclaiming the ' 80s was the turnaround
decade for that so the argument for
Donald Trump's involvement was that he
start he's it really is a simple story
property was cheap there was an
opportunity to create this uh vision of
up like upscale New York living Donald
Trump started to build and develop in
the area and TR and work to convince
many other wealthy people to come back
because it was the cool place to be and
this is where you needed to be with all
the luxury brought back tax revenues and
that's that's that's the very very very
simple version I watched like a a
two-hour documentary breaking down the
real estate development and how it
started to change neighborhoods I I
could see
a a narrative that says you know among
the people who made a change were Donald
Trump but the idea that Donald TR you
know I was there I was there
and it was interesting that Donald Trump
was building luxury housing and he there
was also a very remarkable incident
there was something there there was a
skating rink in Central Park MH that had
been that fall into disrepair like
everything in New York did in the 60s
and
70s and the New York City had been
utterly unable to repair it they could
not wman rink it was called this is a
great story right I love this one
utterly and then just just you know
because all these work rules and all
these unions of Donald
Trump who's in the time was just Donald
Trump okay he just was this guy who you
know who was a real estate developer
says I can do this and the the the C
Administration says all right wise guy
let see you do it and in like three
months he fixed it up he fixes it up
like it's like and it was this this
great free enterprise story that you
know
see what a can do person can do if he's
not working for the go and it was and
that really put him on the map in a sort
of political way that he had not
previously been at the time
but you know New York New York is one of
those places that you can hardly ever
really learn any lessons from that are
applicable to in other words New York
New York is its very own place right
when I grew up the the Garment District
was a place where garments were
manufactured New York was still an
industrial city and it was a shipping
hub neither of which it is at all
anymore well during Co I remember
because I had extra time on my hands
there was a I was always I lived in Bay
Ridge and I was always seeing the I
would like ride my bike down the
greenway and there were the um massive
Ships coming in like those huge cargo
ships there were a ton of them and then
at a certain point it stopped for a
while and I was like that's not good
well but there's very I mean the
shipping just kind of like dried up for
shipping is now basically done in the
port of nework and Elizabeth right you
see those giant
things so New York Harbor wasn't deep
enough to be containerized to take the
big a lot of reasons it had also had to
do with the corruption of the unions on
the on the Docks but the merchant
marines the point which is still you get
you got like you get like uh family
connections to get into the merchant
marines
still the thing though is that New York
despite this despite losing its
industrial base and its and its
transport
significance the way all the great
Northeastern cities did because it had
been a um a a center of
Finance Wall Street kept New York alive
and through the
90s injected me you know when
deregulation came and Wall Street
started becoming the racket that it is
now mass and that happened and then
between kotch and
Giuliani the rebuilding of New York into
a tourist Don um um uh
destination was you know best case
scenario you're never going to make
Cleveland or Philadelphia that kind of
destination they simply doesn't have the
attraction right so New York you can't
even if even if it were true that Donald
Trump did this in New York San Francisco
is at of course actually San Francisco
does have the the tourist aspect to it
but I mean look our my law fir Dylan Law
Group Dylan Law Group um our
headquarters in San Francisco that's
where most that's where most of our
first of all we can't even hire support
staff in San Francisco anymore really
why not they people will not work in the
city in San Francisco I saw this Wild
video today of this woman who was just
in tears and she was like I just got my
first 9 to-5 job after finishing College
you must have seen this talked about it
uh I I can't believe it how do you have
time for having a personal life if you
work a Define job and I was like that
video yeah are you no when we when we
started watching that like I was like
okay dunk on this girl right but it's
like look she's she's not wrong she's
not wrong she's also she's also young
and she will she will eventually the the
pain of coming home from work when it's
dark out will scab over and she'll just
understand that that's the way the world
bar yeah like the rest of us it's very
easy to like like to dunk on stuff like
that cuz that's my first thought was the
same thing like look you got to work
that's the way the world works I'm Sor
you just have to go to work but
sometimes but when I watch that it's was
like look she's if it was like her first
day after her first N9 to-5 shift it
happens she'll change so uh just we're
trying to be careful with this about
about Maine there are some high-profile
accounts tweeting that uh uh some photos
of the suspect have been released oh I'm
seeing that too many people are saying
it's a uh two individuals of Middle
Eastern descent it's very preliminary
there's a police go ahead sorry the
suspect does look like they may be
Middle Eastern the photos released I
don't know for sure um and there's a
police scanner video going around of
what appears to be dispatchers or
someone the police saying two males one
armed with a gun Middle Eastern descent
maroon SUV but we don't know that any of
these things are real and I bring this
up because uh you know if you're in the
area you need you need to stay safe I
don't know if this information could
help but I will say if people are
putting out fake information you need to
make sure you're you're looking toward
towards uh trusted sources and directly
to law enforcement if you're in the area
but uh the the big concern right now is
like there are some parody accounts
tweeting this video this could be a fake
clip of a of a police scan because
people are just trying to sew chaos
which is horrifying and ter it's it's
terrifying I don't know for sure but a
lot of
people uh are saying they've seen
similar things outside of this and a few
high-profile accounts are saying Middle
Eastern uh described as Middle Eastern
so that's that that that's it for now
it's not confirmed don't know please
stay
safe that that you know that was
basically why when you were like it's
you know Maine probably not related I'm
like at just because the guy's middle
eastern doesn't mean it is related but
there's with what we've seen so far you
know there's there's one story we didn't
pull up where a guy broke into the home
of a Jewish Family in California and was
threatening to kill them so yeah that's
crazy too do you want to live in a city
right about now you know where I want to
live is West Virginia it just never
makes we all have guns now the more that
I see all of this stuff in all of these
C and that's what I'm saying like they
don't it doesn't seem like every voting
cycle they ever learned their lesson
right these places become more crimer
ridden with every election cycle it gets
more remember when how long ago is like
like a two months ago when Kai sonat did
like the PlayStation 5 giveaway like
20,000 people showed up and just
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
damage gets
done but look this is my point that that
dude did a a PlayStation giveaway and
people started riding and destroying and
attacking people people were getting
beaten up in the street why there's no
political cause there it doesn't matter
because people go insane in large crowds
so basically cities were just the bad
cities are just the problem it's it's
people being condensed not all people do
you know what's crazy not all people go
insane and large crowds well not all
people do but there I mean I think that
it is I think that everyone has the
capability for to become a monster it's
true that not all people do think I mean
do you think you do do I think I do oh
for sure I don't think you do I think I
I mean I think if I don't think I do I
am at greater risk of becoming a monster
than if I it's not it's not just being a
monster in large in large crowds people
are not just being violent they're also
just being very very stupid so going
insane is not just about a person
deciding to smash a window it's people
acting in irrational ways okay so uh
I got to tell you
something there are people and and
includes everyone in this room right now
who will never be swept away by that
you're correct but it's it's it's a
small number and you have to be aware of
it the five of us well you know what the
the thing is having having been on the
ground and and again I I assume First
Responders can probably speak to this
way better than I but having been in
numerous uh uh conflict situations urban
conflict civil unrest I can tell you
that out of the five 100 people in the
crowd you'll see three act
rationally that's and and the rest are
just it's you wonder why someone would
do such a thing like um you ever watch
Indian January 6 by the way no January
6th frankly there were
people it was dumb to go in the first
place it was an OB it was an obvious
trap whether you whether it was meant
set up as a trap by the government or
not I'm not even getting into but you'd
have to be a schmuck I think but people
who did not go there looking to make
trouble definitely lost their head but
it's it's not that's not that's not
necessarily what I mean uh have you ever
seen the movie Prometheus no have you
guys seen Prometheus Brad of course seen
all of it okay you know the scene when
the giant ring ship is rolling forward
and okay so it's a gigantic spaceship
it's a big donut and it is rolling and
there is a person running in the line of
the ship as it's about to crush them and
they get crushed and you ask yourself
like that was dumb why didn't they run
to the left yeah and it's like I wonder
why and and it's like it kind of you're
like that's stupid if I was doing it
psych let me tell you let me tell you I
have been at so many riots where people
have been shot and everyone runs
straight down the line of where the
person is shooting and being chased and
I've just been like why do they do that
because people just go insane public
panic and and and my attitude is just
like why did you not turn left and like
just break away from the crowd you may
you may be more able to think like in a
in a high press situation you may be
more prone to think rationally than
other people are well I think it it it
could be experience yes but I think this
is my point is that it's not just about
whether they're going to attack it's
about the general breakdown of cognitive
function and right now we're in a
society like a lot of these they're
young people right uh we have a heavily
medicated Society we have a very very
Doris Society right now where kids are
angry kids are upset they're being
constantly bombarded with fear porn
about climate change about all of these
things they're told the world's going to
end in 12 years by politician
and you wonder why people are so on edge
and so easy to push to violence or push
to my wife is always referring now on
strike for Gaza the well respected and
highly accomplished um writer for legal
Insurrection Jane Coleman who is Mrs
Coleman my wife um is always referring
to the work about uh crowd Psychology by
Elias Kennedy and he deals with but what
Tim is talking about here is the the you
know and and in his work he really
expands the application to of crowd
psychology
to a tremendous number of phenomena in
society um but he would you know you
should look at that book uh Tim and tell
me what's in it besides because between
you and Jane I'll have to I don't have
to read it oh he won the Nobel Prize in
1981 that guy he he was he was quite he
was quite a big deal
very you know and and and that's what
we're talking about here is this the The
Madness of crowds M um and you know I I
don't want to I don't want to be um you
know unrealistic about it I recognize
that that but but I do think that you
know people who are more civilized will
act more civilized in large numbers and
people who are less civilized will act
less civilized in you know in large
numbers and we once thought we had a
civilization here well we did have a
civilization when we built it and we
built it so big and so strong that it's
taking a long time to crumble and then
what happened was we started saying we
should work really really hard to make
sure people who are unwell can continue
to be a part of our society and there's
but there's good things about that we
want to help people survive right well
there there's the unwell I mean public
there's what's happened to public spaces
in general this that's the San Francisco
story right is that we gave up the the
the idea that a society is entitled
to not necessarily act cruel cruy
towards people who are unwell but to
protect itself and its spaces and its
children and its vulnerable people
people and its vulnerable people from
those who are unwell that's one issue
then there's the other issue of the
importation
of pre
premodern societal units that's a crazy
thing that's happening right now the
importation of as you say pre pre what
did you say pre premodern societal units
you I mean that is pretty wacky and then
that's where we and then also refusing
to encourage assimilation and telling
them that their culture is better than
ours well so there's a story that I I I
was told I can't remember I heard this
about a Saudi Arabian town that had a
lot of oil and uh for the entirety of
their their their small Town's existence
it was very
tribal no computers phones none of this
stuff and then when oil was discovered
they were all of a sudden very very very
wealthy and they did not adapt very very
well to having Mass wealth and what
happened was they were just covered in
gold chains and rubies and jewelry to
them when you when when you're in living
J the status symbols were not fancy cars
was not big skyscrapers and Pen houses
it wasn't the luxury infinity pool it
was gold and chains and things like this
and having your jewelry so when they got
a lot of money they just Amplified
everything that was about luxury to them
so they ended up just covering
themselves in gold and uh that was
basically explained to me as like what
happens when you abruptly just give
maximum wealth to one group of people
and it's and it really is it's
regardless of uh uh the level of
development this this Behavior exists
and and it's obvious because you can
only know what you know for instance if
you go to your average American and give
them a ton of money what are they going
to do they're going to buy a big house
they're going to get a big pool they're
not going to act outside of societal
Norms lottery winners why so many
lottery winners end up losing most of
the money because they did not uh how
they end up getting to it they don't
actually know how to invest or how to
build the wealth but it's not just that
it's like you know Elon Musk wants to
build a spaceship the average person who
gets billions of dollars doesn't build a
spaceship yeah they they want to do
things that they they that they believe
is luxury and and their desire so nice
cars big houses you know big big
properties and things like that many of
them don't go and buy horses but horses
are are expensive and horses can be
considered dress of fancy no no it's you
they don't act outside of their their
culture so if you bring people into the
United States that go from an
impoverished City in you know Honduras
into the US they're going to with access
to these resources amplify them in a way
more uh more akin to their society and
less akin to to to ours right it's not
about level of technological development
right if if if if they have certain
behaviors when they get money they go
out and have this special kind of party
with 13 kinds of booze or whatever
they'll do that same thing here and then
we'll say things like shouldn't they be
taking care of their house and whatever
shouldn't the people in this small
village be installing plumbing and like
buying cars and building roads we're so
shocked they buy gold and jewelry and
gems
of the well okay but I I think on the
other end of the scale the point you're
making
is the fallacy of
liberalism one of the great fallacies of
liberalism has always
been poverty is what makes
people
misbehave and the fact that's still the
line why do people why do Palestinians
from
Gaza Massacre people and and burn them
alive poverty it's asinine it's an
asinine rap well that's that's an that's
an extreme Le listen I think poverty is
a huge component of it's a component but
the point is you have
societies that have lacked
wealth forever and have nonetheless been
stable nonviolent like what
um
well
the Eastern European Jews
were remarkably poor in the 20th century
and certainly those in the pale
settlement in Russia um but they were a
minority they were a minority so it's
maybe not a very good example but well
no no no look look stable society and so
and so was Yemen for example the AR
Moroccans and Yemen in other words much
of much of the of the of the Middle East
before the Western Powers started
screwing things so like before the 40s I
would say really before the before well
before the 40s I would say you know the
19th century the 20th century you know
it's when
the they were they were dirt poor these
were these you know these these were
really remember petroleum is not a
factor so there's no reason you know
it's been it's been Millennia since
spice Roots mattered right and and
petroleum is not a thing yet so what is
making Arab societies wealthy nothing
they're not wealthy they're poor
but I mean homogeneity is is an issue
also but the point is they had stability
and they and you don't have to be poor
to
be you know uh to be violent or to be
unhappy or to or to or to or to
misbehave socially a big issue in
America right now it's not about wealthy
and Port it's about wealth inequality
which has become a big striking point
for a lot of those people right well I
think that's it right that's why the
point I was going to make is if you go
back 200 years what what is the saying
uh you have better a poor person has
better Dental Care today than
Rockefeller did you know 100 whatever
years ago technological development so
now poor people have air conditioning
they have refrigeration they have clean
running water and they have Cheetos they
have Cheetos I mean America tacom people
po we have fat homeless people that's
right poor poor the surviving get
getting the calories you need to survive
is not an
issue uh no there's plenty of that right
in fact it's an issue that we get too
many this country has too much too many
calories too many calories we got to get
rid of some of those calories but so
much of it is is like you look there are
large social programs for people who are
unable to pay for food who are unable to
pay we do take care in a lot of ways our
social programs do cover a lot of that
but there's still this large call for
discussions about wealth inequality that
leads to violence at a lot of these at
least what it seems like to me right
like a lot of what we're talking about
it's telling you the Millionaires and
the billionaires oh sorry it's just the
billionaires now because Bernie Sanders
he's a millionaire but yeah it's that's
the the rallying cry thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net